hi everyone out in YouTube land thank
you so much for joining us today as
always I am Yuri Greenstein your host
and I'm incredibly excited today because
for the first time we have guests in the
studio we have cherylin and Christophe
from elastic Salzburg
sure thanks Yuri hi my name is Shirley
nu and I'm from elastic I'm on the
business development team so very happy
to be here today thanks for having us
and I guess I'm Christopher I'm a
principal solution architect I work with
all of their users and customers that we
have here in the Bay Area awesome I'm
really excited thank you so much for
taking the time to join us so they're
really appreciate it I imagine a lot of
folks online have probably heard of
elastic and they know what you all do
but I think they would also like to hear
it from you as well so showing can you
tell us a bit about elastic absolutely
so ask you sets for those who are not
familiar with us here's a little bit of
history of elastic so it's all started
back in 2010 when our CEO Shannon he was
working in London and he wanted to
create a recipe search engine for his
wife now at that point in time there
wasn't any great kind of open source
text search engine out there so what he
do
was like I'm gonna create my own what
she decided to call it elastic search
made it open source and put on github
yeah and then the community picked it up
you know people really liked it and at
the very beginning people mostly use it
for search textures to purpose so the
early adopters would be like Wikipedia
they spoke github and just on search
engine for a bunch of websites and then
sooner or later people will realize that
hey you know elasticsearch has more than
just text search you can use it for
searching through machine data for locks
and metrics I mean it makes sense
because elastic search is really fast
scales really well and it has real time
read and write so it becomes you know
more and more popular and then we start
building tools around it so say for
example there is lost - for ingestion
and there's cabana and for visualization
and that gives us the acronym of log
stash and key bottom up so you just said
something that's really interesting you
said that the company started when
you found to put some code on github
obviously here you will we are very much
committed to you know open source
philosophy and support in the open
source community is elastic still open
search or sorry open source so is your
code still open source absolutely so we
are at the core open source but we also
build and developed a bunch of other
commercial functionalities around it so
that you know to assist the users in the
community out there for example there is
security monitoring alerting and the
Machine early and crystal would be
showing off a bit of those and enough in
a few seconds awesome that's that's
really cool I'm actually excited to hear
that and obviously you know Eliquis
something that I hear about a lot and I
work with a bunch of customers they they
use elastic you know I've always heard
good things about it something that I
think everyone I've ever talked has
always had good things about it so I'm
excited to have you all here thank you
so much for doing this so maybe at this
point it might make sense for Christoph
to you kind of take us one level down
and kind of show us how how to use
elastic what it can do for folks and I
think one of the things obviously that
I'm interested in is you know how can
the folks that are in GCP use it yeah
yeah for sure do you wanna share my
screen yeah see that great so here we
have the the Google cloud platform
launcher which which most of you will be
familiar with and what you can do is we
have we have several ways off of
deployment and you can of course just
done with the software there's some
source after all you can just download
it and run it on on just GCP instances
but what we also offer is we also offer
a fully managed service a hosted service
where we run the software for you and
we're in Google launcher so what you can
do is you can search for we call it
elastic cloud so if you search for that
here it's it's going to appear and then
if you click on the link of some
information here and then if you click
on the link you get our website and the
way it looks is it's like this so here
basically in this in this UI you specify
the the cluster size you have this nice
slider here we can just determine the
size of cluster you want you can choose
the GCP region that you want to get it
that you want to be in we have four
regions available you can also choose
how many availability zones you want to
have depending on
mission criticality of the cluster you
can choose things like versions and
various other other settings but then at
the end of there you simply click create
and within a few minutes we're going to
spin up a new cluster for you and then
we're going to give you the URL that you
can use to to log in and just do
everything that you want to do so you
actually just show something really
interesting I've obviously seen a lot of
solutions that are available on the
cloud launcher but most of them when you
hit that button what it does is
basically deploys stuff on compute
engine yeah right so can it goes out
there install the software and then
you're interacting with it using your
you know typically maybe your private IP
czar your public IP s but it's really
just again it's basically a installer
yeah whereas what you're will you just
shown us is actually a fully managed
service that you just happens to use GCP
as the backend correct correct yeah and
the backup of course we also have TCP
instances but the TCP instances that we
manage and we just deploy there are our
users and customers clusters on it and
then just manage it on our side and give
you the the API endpoint to use so I
think it's it's just it's just much more
management easier to use that way very
cool all right so now that we have a
good idea how do I get started
show us what you can do once you have
the cluster yeah yeah of course
so um once you have the cluster set up
like one of the things that you have to
do is to get the data and I'm not going
to show that here but it's relatively
simple to do we integrate with a number
of with a number of services on TCP as
well so I think the common ones would be
something like the data flow or pops up
that we can integrate with to get to
receive the data and then store it in
elasticsearch the data store and then on
top of that we have what you see here
which is Cubana the user interface and
there's really several things that you
can do here one of the things I'm
showing around here so one thing that
you can do is you can just look at your
data so here we have some some web
blocks that we've gathered from our own
website Lassa cocoa about six weeks
worth of LOC data from early 2017
and what we can see here is just the
requests over time as well as the
individual requests and what we could do
now is we could drill down into each of
them what I want to show here is some
four things that you can that you can
search and filter so for example we have
a search bar up here and I can search
for for example a city
and we get all of the requests from the
city we've we've enriched the data as it
was coming in we just got up here
dresses but then you can match the
appear dress to the city in the country
in the continent that it's coming from
and we did that here before we actually
before we persisted persisted the data
and so here further down on on just
Paris and so we can see all of the
requests that we go in from Paris what
we could do is we could further filter
down on for example a specific specific
ul I mean now we see all of the requests
from Paris that were they were looking
at this this blog post yeah one of these
I'm actually impressed with already this
is pretty quick you started out with
something like 14 million rows yeah you
just got it down to 14 hits I mean it
was fast yeah yeah we try to we try we
try
like we rebuild a lot of data structures
in the background to make it fast
indexers and then we also take advantage
of multiple levels of caching to make
sure that especially heavily access data
is fast
ss-sure Landsat like kind of the reason
to use elastic search for something is
if you if you need near real-time access
to your data if you need to write huge
volumes of data very quickly but also if
you need to access it very quickly and
if you do something like if you have
something like web blocks or your
metrics or if you're doing website
search then then fast access to data is
essential mm-hmm so let me ask you a
question and you can tell me if you
think that the this answer is perhaps
too complex to address here obviously if
you're running on GCP you know your
logging is being generated by
stackdriver
yeah is there a simple mechanism to get
all that logs or get all those logs into
elasticsearch yeah there is so stack
drive integrates with Google pops up
mm-hm and then Google pops up can feed
into into elastic very cool yeah so you
know exporting lots of pops up is
something that lots of customers do
typically they will often then take them
into something big for you from there
yeah but sending them to elastic for you
know the kind of analysis that you've
shown us is really useful in gems like
it pretty easy to do yeah
all right so let's continue yeah of
course
so one one more thing that we can do
here is that we might want to do this we
might want to look at a specific user
and just look at what this user has been
doing um so let's just pick I always
love doing live demos so let's just pick
a random IP address from here and let's
see
works so if we living on the edge
absolutely so if we take this this one
request the one can do is let's look at
the at the call the surrounding
documents let's filter down on just this
up here s and then what we can see is we
can see this up here dress has requested
a certain blog post and if we go further
back we can see that right before that
it was now down last page so currently
downloading lassic search before that
was on our product page for elastic
search and before that on our generic
product page the kind of a normal
customer user flow that we can observe
here you could imagine using this for
something like root cause analysis where
you have some kind of error message that
you're looking for some kind of
exception that you've seen the log so
that some user has told you about and
you want to see what happened exactly
before this error message what what led
up to this error message and this is the
kind of view where you would do that
exploring the data absolutely makes a
lot of sense yeah now exploring the raw
data is one way to look at it and then
the other way that you can look at your
data is to aggregate to look at the look
at the big picture and so we can do is
we can build we can build visualizations
and then out of these visualizations we
can both dashboards let's look at what
that looks like here's so simple
visualization is as always the pie chart
here we can see this pie chart is
showing the different HTTP response
codes that we see in our web block so
the majority off response codes are 200
us everything's fine that's good but
then we also have a sizable 30 percent
of our web blocks that are 4 4 or so
people or applications trying to access
part of our website that we this request
failed and so we might want to explore
this a little bit further what kind of
requests were these where they're coming
from what IP addresses what URLs what
resources did these these people try to
access and so for that you probably want
a dashboard and here we have such a
dashboard it's showing a lot of
different things things like where our
requests coming from we have a we have a
map up here but also how many requests
do we have 14 million and then various
other charts where we break things down
by response code by a number of unique
IP addresses and where visitors by
operators
by browser and by the resources in their
piece at the accessing and actually up
there at the bottom here we also have
the raw request so in this dashboard we
can both see the visualizations where we
aggregating but we can also see the raw
requests that both together now what I
want might want to do here is because I
saw quite a number of for ferris I might
want to understand better what what led
to these and what these for force even
are some one thing I can do is I can
filter down to just a for for us and I
see an interesting thing here where my
number of for four hours over time we're
relatively constant and relatively low
and since suddenly it's spiked and there
might be something interesting to look
into that was really fast you were able
to fill it and then they actually
refreshed every element in the dashboard
yeah in what looked like to be less than
a second I mean that is really
impressive performance yeah thank you
yeah definitely I mean this is what you
need right like this is what you need
when you do some kind of some kind of
food cost analysis of bakes data
exploration you're trying to find out
what's happening with your system right
now and so speed is key mm-hmm
say we can see we can see off the 430 of
you have a spike in the for four hours
and and that's something interesting
that that I want to dive deeper into you
and I could now do things like look at
the raw requests and maybe put it on
even more but there's one more thing
that that I want to show here and that
is how we do anomaly attention anomaly
detection or we also call it machine
learning is one of the month of
commercial features that we have for
enterprises that users and so I just
want to quickly show what that looks
like so for that let's create one of
those anomaly detection machine learning
jobs so what I can do here in this in
this interface is so therefore you
created can you explain the terminology
here yeah what is a job in the elastic
euro system obviously everyone uses the
term jobs and yeah everyone kind of
attaches a different meaning to it
that's a good point that's a good point
yeah so so a job in that context this
when we do anomaly detection you usually
want to do some kind of analysis on your
on your historical data that you have
you in this case bode have six weeks
worth of data so we're going to we want
to analyze these six weeks worth of data
and all that is something that we don't
necessarily want to do want to do
synchronously but it's something that
could happen the background acid
chronically so that's what called a job
now everything else that we've seen so
far every search that I've done the
filtering looking at surrounding
documents the dashboard and the
filtering in the dashboard all of that
are synchronous requests weren't like
I've done something and then I've had to
wait a little bit for it to show up now
that works when I'm doing these signal
requests but when I'm doing something
like anomaly detection on six weeks
worth of data then no matter how fast we
are it's gonna take some time
sure and so that's what we need to
create job and then the job runs in the
background to create these anomalies and
then also just keeps running as new data
keeps coming in and just keeps creating
finding these anomalies okay cool thank
you yeah sure thanks for asking so here
in this here in this UI we can see how
we create such a job what we try to do
is we've tried to abstract away a lot of
the lot of complexities off anomaly
detection it's kind of a once once we
tried it internally or somebody like
once the developers tried internally to
explain to us how the anomaly detection
actually works the math behind it and
well I'm afraid I didn't understand a
lot of it but we try to do is we try to
abstract away all of the other fiddle
complexities of it and just give our
users a nice UI and there's also an API
to use it to make it usable for for
everybody now in this case I have web
block data so what I want to look at is
maybe I want to look at the number of
visitors on my website it's kind of an
important KPI for every website to track
that and so I can see this from my web
blocks what I have to do is let's look
at the unique count the distinct count
of IP addresses and in a second here we
should be seeing just the general up and
down that the data like this shows us
and again while we're waiting can you
explain kind of what nice I see I see
that you can click on the little eyes to
kind of get a explanation of that
particular feature but what is a what is
a bucket span mmm good point yeah so
what we need to do is the number of
visitors has to be only makes sense in a
certain time frame and how many visitors
have you had in
one minute on five minutes on twenty
minutes and so it kind of controls the
buckets pan controls the granularity of
the analysis that makes sense yeah so
here we're looking at at 15 minutes
minutes buckets pans now here we can see
the data aggregators and we can already
visually see that there's probably some
kind of anomaly here in the in the in
the latter half of the data now if we
had a dashboard or visualization that
we're showing executives that this is
something that we would probably see
visually but the whole point is of
anomaly detection especially this kind
of automated non detection is to not
actually have to have this to not
actually have somebody looking at these
dashboards and visualizations all the
time so the goal of this job is to
basically find this anomaly as well as
any other normal ease that might exist
in here that we haven't that we don't
see visually now I don't need to do
anything else I'm just going to give it
a name and and create the job and
because this is a relatively simple job
I'm just looking at the number of
visitors over time it's just one metric
and it should be relatively it should be
relatively quick a line you can actually
watch it work in real time it's actually
showing you the data it's already
analyzed yeah yeah it shows you how it
builds the model in real time and how it
finds the anomalies and so it seems that
it is actually Fantine only that we were
looking for now what we could do now is
one thing that we could do is we could
just continue running this job any new
data that comes soon is compared against
the against the model that we built in
the background and then any anomalies
being found we could do something like
get an email or an alert of some sort
but let's look at the results here so if
you look at the results like let's look
at the let's look at the very beginning
that's kind of interesting to look at
how this how this anomaly detection
works so if we can see here the the
first three days of data we haven't
gotten we didn't really get it good we
didn't get a good lead the model the the
shaded area and background is relatively
imprecise it just has an upper and lower
bound but then as we kind of go further
into the future we can see how how the
model tracks the data pretty pretty well
yeah and I mean generally that's one of
the expectations you'll have with
machine learning right is it the more
data you have the more analysis you do
the more precise your results are going
to be the better the trained the model
is and over time your results should get
better and better it makes a lot of
sense yeah and so we can
see here that it has finally found a
normally they were looking for this was
a this is real data so this actually
happened to us on on and this looks like
a Monday morning we had our usual
spiking visitors as people come to work
and they start working and they using
elastic so they're looking at the
website for different things and then we
suddenly had a big drop down in our
number of visitors here we can see this
visually but we can also have to look
into the table down here where we can
see that we were expecting the typical
number of visitors during this time was
about a thousand four hundred and fifty
thousand 450 visitors but we actually
only hit 86 in this time so that is that
is 17 times lower then then what we're
expecting so it's very Konami and that's
why we market red and we give it a very
high score yeah so am I gonna spoil it
by asking you whether you actually can
use this to tell it to know what
happened or do you know what happened so
here's actually we do know what happened
what we did is we have a we have a condo
management system behind a website like
everybody else and you know every once
in a while we make it change and usually
the changes you know no problem like
nothing but happens but sometimes you
make a change that doesn't work out
really well yeah so here we made a
change that just broke a bunch of links
on our website and so but we roll it
back fairly quickly so like you can
actually tell if you look at the data
huh I mean it went right back up so you
know whoever was on call that day really
quickly yeah yeah yeah that's that's the
value of it right like it tells you
really quickly that something bad is
happening something that you might
otherwise I mean maybe have missed if
you looked if you have looked at the
data in any other way and then you can
react to it win exactly and that goes
back to like a point about speed we want
to be fast we we're kind of the tool for
accessing any kind of data we quickly
especially the ones that like real-time
auto generate data things like machine
data
yeah it's different ways the things that
you can do with it switch it filter it
aggregated or do anomaly detection on it
awesome very cool well thank you so much
for the demo that was really informative
I hope folks on the line learned as well
yeah if you wanted to tell people like
what they should do next what would you
recommend
oh yeah sure so yeah if you want use
elastic I think the easiest way to get
started with it is to actually used the
Google cloud launcher that I was sowing
showing earlier I think everybody
probably has a Google account so just go
in there just search for elastic cloud
and spin out maybe a really small
instance just to get started with get
some data and maybe from stackdriver and
[Music]
then see what you get and see what you
do with it yeah very cool I think that
was like the kind of second half of what
I was gonna say is it's really easy get
started right go to the launcher sign up
and kind of get it rolling and then from
there like the easiest way to get data
into it which is obviously what you need
for analytics tool like this to be
useful is yeah set up the stackdriver
integration right just get start getting
logs from GCP flowing via pub/sub and
then go into elastic and then you can
get this stuff you know really easily
really quickly yeah awesome they say
thank you both so much for being here
today where I was always really
appreciative thank you for your time
thanks for coming in teaching us about
elastic to everyone out there thank you
so much for taking the time to tune in
we really appreciate it as always I like
rate subscribe right that's what the
kids I need to say these days that's
right lots of likes and we'll be back on
Thursday morning with another customer
story and we've got lots more exciting
stuff for you for the rest of the month
and hopefully the rest of the year so
thank you so much thanks again to
elastic for being here thanks for
bringing your stickers thank you whole
pile of stickers on the table really
appreciate it's a pleasure hi folks have
a great day